[Music]
season 5 begins issa's career journey
she's building off of the success of the
block party
issa and molly's relationship is really
the backbone of the show you're going to
see a relationship that was fragile
try and rebuild theirs is a friendship
that makes sense and kelly is just
trying to give them insight with the
hope that they figure it out i can be in
there for her you know what makes her
scared what makes her hair grow there
were so many moments last season that
threw us for a loop there are no less in
this season lawrence is having a baby
with canola we found ourselves towards
the end of season four in this really
beautiful place and now there's some
things that he has to figure out
what does that mean
this season on the show is sort of the
crescendo to four seasons of friendships
and growth y'all ain't ready y'all aim
ready
[Music]
i hope people feel like they're cool
with these characters riding off to the
sunset i've seen dms from y'all so i
know that's not how it's gonna go down
it's so good like it's so good i know
reading the scripts i was in tears and
laughing
i'm looking a little bit scared how
viewers are gonna react to the final
season
make your opinions known there's not
much i can do about it at this point but
no episodes will still be a half an hour
[Music]
you